now all you know it's a good day when I
get to talk about hockey that means
things are right in the world UNLV
hockey going to the acha national
championships in Boston but they need
your help to get there Nick raboni is
with us here from the program to talk
about a Gala that's being held to try
and raise money to get the team out
there the national championships are in
Boston and UNLV one of the top teams in
the country you got to get there too
thanks for joining us first of all let's
talk about this event you guys are
hosting this week yeah thanks for having
me so tomorrow night we have our Rebels
with the cause Gala um it's going to be
from 6 30 to 9 30 at a simple Affair in
Summerlin unfortunately right now
tickets are sold out however you can
still bid on our silent auction at
rebelhockey.com that's going to help us
go a long way we got some great prizes
whether it's top tier golf some Rebel
hockey swag or or even some Vegas golden
knights signs and stuff now for those
who don't know I was at the rebel game
on Friday night tell us about the rebel
hockey program and uh the involvement
that it has with the school it's not an
NCAA program but it certainly is still
very much involved with the school it's
not an NCAA program but we pride
ourselves in running the program as if
we were already there so it is
considered Club quote unquote uh the
school helps us out a little bit but our
budget alone is about five hundred
thousand dollars every year and this
trip to Boston is going to be upwards of
about fifty thousand dollars so we rely
heavily on our sponsors donors and the
community to to really help us reach
those goals and you guys one of the top
teams in the country what do you guys
ranked right now in the acha D1 yeah
three-ish we're ranked second right now
second okay 22 three and one you know
who's counting
um but it's been a great year someone is
yeah yeah it's been a great year for us
and our guys have put in a lot of time
and effort and we've played some
exhibition NCAA D1 games this year to
kind of help us prepare for this
National Tournament run and you know the
program has been around for for a long
time now but it seems like it's made a
lot of big strides in the last few years
what is the energy like around you know
for the UNLV kids the students for you
and involved with the program really
accelerating things and getting College
hockey on the map here in town you know
we owe lots of Vegas golden knights we
wouldn't be where we're at today without
that practice facility having that
locker room and and having a place for
our guys to really call home but yeah
when you come to a game there's there's
not an atmosphere really like it I mean
there's 800 900 to 1000 fans packed in
City National Arena everybody's pounding
on the glass it's a really fun
environment and it's uh it's cheap
tickets you know you're looking at five
ten dollars to come to a game and uh I
think that the product on the ice gets
better every year finally if people want
to get involved you mentioned the gala
is sold out but if people want to get
involved in the auctions how can they do
that yeah rebelhockey.com or you can go
to 32auctions.com backslash Rebels with
a cause that'll take you directly to the
link and like I said we got some great
auction items on there we'll get that
information online as well Nick raboni
from the UNLV hockey program good luck
in Boston to the national championships
hope to uh see you guys come back with
the title and uh appreciate you coming
in this morning thanks appreciate you
having me all right next you're on Good
Day Las Vegas even more Good Day Las
Vegas